good evening and welcome to everyone in
this room and in the other two rooms
that are filled with our guests tonight
it is an absolute delight to have so
many people here for tonight's lecture
and I hope we see you all at the rest of
the aesthetic activism symposium
tomorrow and on Saturday tonight's and
tomorrow night's talks and the events of
the next two days together make up our
ninth J or when Miller's symposium the
nine symposia have all been supported by
an endowment established in 2010 by the
kind generosity of mr. Miller's children
Catherine Margaret Elizabeth and will we
are grateful to the Miller family for
choosing to honor the memory of their
fathers through a gift to the School of
Architecture jr. when Miller was born
was a 1931 Phi Beta Kappa graduate of
Yale College where he majored in Greek
and Latin
after Yale he continued his education at
Oxford University where he studied
philosophy politics and economics and in
1934 he began his professional career
with the family business Cummins engine
company ultimately serving as president
and chairman and in that capacity hiring
good architects graphic designers
landscape architects including Eero
Saarinen Kevin Roche dan Kiley and
Alexander Girard Cummins was and also is
still noted for hiring male and female
engineers from diverse backgrounds from
around the world mr. Miller was an
extraordinary person a successful
businessman a leader nationally and in
his community a loyal alumnus of Yale I
have to get that in there and a fierce
advocate for freedom of choice and a
believer an opportunity for all his
great respect for the power of
architecture improved to improve public
life is reflected in the famous
programme of patronage he established in
his home city of Columbus Indiana he was
a man of great curiosity and intellect
an outstanding citizen and embodiment of
ethical behavior a model for us all
perhaps most particularly these days
before introducing the introducer of
tonight's speaker I would like to
express my appreciation to the very many
who helped make this weekend's events
possible particularly Richard de Fleur
Murray Robbie Lynne Hanoi and who are
schools special events coordinators and
to associate dean John Jacobson each of
whom has contributed mightily to the
smooth running I hope smooth running and
the massive coordination that this all
required my sincere thanks also to the
architects artists academics students
thinkers and Friends of the school who
have joined us for this event it is now
my pleasure to introduce associate
professor and assistant dean Marc Foster
gage who organized this J Irwin Miller
symposium Marc received his Bachelor of
architecture from Notre Dame in 1997 and
a Master of Architecture from Yale in
2001 combining teaching with writing and
professional practice Marc's design work
has been exhibited in institutions
including the Museum of Modern Art the
Museum of the Art Institute of Chicago
the Venice Biennale the Beijing Biennale
and the Prague Biennale of experimental
architecture among many others
Marc's work has also been published in
venues as varied as vogue Fast Company
the New York Times and Harper's Bazaar
and has been seen on PBS Fox and MTV he
has designed architectural projects
across a variety of topologies ranging
from the new live Art Center at Bard
College to the 20-story Orem residential
tower in Manhattan please join me in
welcoming to the podium Marc Foster gage
Thank You Deborah I was beautiful
introduction I always wish my mom was in
the audience when I hear beautiful
introductions about me she'll have to
watch the video welcome to everyone in
this room and also in the overflow rooms
I think it's a great testament to Elaine
Scarry straw that we have filled nearly
three rooms full of people eager to hear
her I'm gonna be giving the opening talk
to this symposium proper tomorrow at
10:00 a.m. when we reconvene and that
panel will feature Keller Easterling
Katherine Ingram
Timothy Morton and it's moderated by
Jonathan Massey so we encourage you all
to come for that as well as the rest of
the symposium I wanted to start with a
reading from the book of scary a
beautiful face drawn by Verrocchio
glides into the perceptual field of a
young boy named Leonardo the boy copies
the face then copies the face again then
again and again and again he does the
same thing when a beautiful living plant
a violet a wild rose glides into his
field of vision or a living face he
makes a first copy the second copy a
third a fourth a fifth he draws it over
and over just as Pater
who tells us all this about Leonardo
replicates now in sentences Leonardo
sacks so that the essay reenacts its
subject these are some of the opening
lines of Elaine's scariest book on
beauty and being just with which she
describes how beauty migrates through
both time and culture to me their exact
recitation is the only way to illustrate
not only that is Elaine Scarry is
writing courageous for nearly 20 years
ago addressing what I would consider to
be the then third rail of philosophy
beauty but it's the writing itself
borders on being a form of intellectual
lyrical sorcery his most beautiful form
of irony that Elaine writes about beauty
with staggering beauty professor Gary is
intellectual reach however far exceeds
beauty and extends into the darker
territories of human experience
she writes courageously on to notice
examples torture and injury in the body
in the body and pain the making and
making of the world on crisis behavior
in thinking in an emergency and most
recently about constitutional injustice
thermonuclear monarchy choosing between
democracy and doom which seems an apt
title for our upcoming election Elaine
Scarry received her BA from Chatham
College and a PhD from the University of
Connecticut prior to teaching at the
University of Pennsylvania from 1974
until 1989
since then she has occupied the position
of the Walter M Kappa professor of
aesthetics and general theory of value
at Harvard University professor scary's
list of achievements and honors is vast
she has received a Truman Coty award a
Truman Capote award for literary
criticism was published in the
anthologies the best American Essays in
1995 2003 and 2007 and has been listed
as one of the top 100 leading public
intellectuals by both Prospect magazine
and foreign policy professor Scarry has
also received an honorary doctorate of
Humane Letters from Northwestern
University and was inducted into the
American Philosophical Society as a
member in 2013 it is an honor to welcome
Elaine Scarry to Yale as she now places
you in the role of the young Leonardo
and glides into your own perceptual
field to deliver the opening dress for
the symposium aesthetic activism as she
delivers her much-anticipated lecture
building and breath beauty and the pact
of aliveness
well it's always a deep pleasure to be
at Yale and I'm very very happy to be
here tonight when people will talk about
beauty they're sometimes talking about
the beautiful object itself which might
be a formation of clouds in the sky or
it might be a beautiful face or it might
be a mathematical proof and at other
times when they talk about beauty
they're really talking about the
perceptual event that happens to the
perceiver and one thing that's been true
over many many centuries is that poets
and philosophers have described the
relation between the perceiver of beauty
and the beautiful object itself as a
life pact for example in eighth century
BC Homer wrote the Odyssey and there's a
moment in the Odyssey when after having
been nearly killed at sea Odysseus is
washed up on an island where a beautiful
young girl named Nausicaa lives and when
Odysseus sees Nausicaa he realizes that
he's been saved from the man-killing
ocean you might think that Odysseus
would feel that sense of relief and life
affirmation at the moment when he first
sees the shore coming into view after
scores of days on the ocean but actually
as you can see from this passage when he
gets in sight of shore he feels no
relief at all but when he was as far
away as a man's voice carries when he
shouts and heard the boom of the sea
upon the reefs for the great wave
thundered against the dry land belching
upon it in terrible fashion and all
things were wrapped in the foam of the
sea for there were neither harbours
where ships might ride nor rode steeds
but projecting headlands and reefs and
cliffs then the knees of Odysseus were
loosened and his heart melted nowhere
does there appear a way to come forth
from the grey sea for without our sharp
crags and around them the wave roars
foaming and the rock runs up Scheer and
the water is deep close inshore so that
in no
is it possible to plant both feet firmly
and escape ruin it's also the case that
once he arrives unsure he feels no
relief and I won't read this whole
passage but it begins and all this flesh
was swollen and see water flowed and
streams up through his mouth and
nostrils he's vomiting seawater and he
says no matter where I am I'm gonna be
killed
I can either lie here on the beach in
which case I'm gonna freeze and get sick
and die or I can make my way up to the
woods and fall asleep there and then
I'll be eaten I'll be taken as prey by
an animal it's only when he sees
Nausicaa that he suddenly describes
himself as having been rescued from the
man-killing sea and that description is
given in a very similar way about twelve
centuries later when Saint Augustine on
the northern coast of Africa writes a
treatise called de musica in which he
describes the importance of symmetry and
equality in all kinds of phenomena such
as dance steps and smooth surfaces and
rose petals but first and foremost in
music itself and he describes music as a
life-saving plank in the midst of the
ocean if we trip forward a number of
centuries again to the early 14th
century the or the very end of the 13th
century
we know that when Dante saw the face of
Beatrice he wrote The Divine Comedy but
before he wrote The Divine Comedy he
wrote a little book in 1294 that was
simply about the fact of having seen
Beatrice and it just again and again
shows him not even talking to her but
crossing her path on the street and that
book is called la Vita Nuova
the new life that intuition that when
you come into the presence of beauty
you're in the presence of new life is
also saluted by the 20th century poet
Rilke who in the poem about the archaic
torso of Apollo which is a very
beautiful poem
about the fact that this statue though
it has no head is and I don't know why
this arrow is shimmery am i doing
something wrong
the the the poem is about the fact that
the Apollo is headless the because the
luminosity of his gaze the brightness of
his vision shines out from his whole
torso and a smile breaks across the
curve of his hips and thighs thank you
Thank You Trevor so the the we can see
that that beauty is is a life pact in
the case of poets and we can also see
this in philosophers for example in
concert he associates beauty with
aliveness continually now usually in
accounts of the third critique this
feature isn't mentioned but there is a
philosopher at Emory University named
Rudolph McCrea who's written about the
third critique who makes it very evident
how important that feature is to [ __ ]
and so far I've only been citing poets
and philosophers but people in all kinds
of fields have noted this for example
the the archaeologists and religion
scholar named Francesco Polizzi notes
that when he talked to one Native
American people and asked them what in
their language was the word for
beautiful they responded by saying it
was the word alive another example from
a seemingly very distant field comes
from the astrophysicist Mario Livio who
works at the Hubble Space Telescope and
who he wrote a book about symmetry and
beauty and symmetry all throughout the
universe including in very small patches
close to home such as the letters of the
alphabet
that many letters in our alphabet have
bilateral symmetry if you put a line
through the a or the H or the amur the O
it will be the same on the left side as
on the right side but that doesn't tell
anything about the affirmation of life
what does tell something about the
affirmation of life is that he goes on
to speak about palindromes which are
sequences of letters that read the same
way forward as backward and he notes
that the y chromosome is made up of many
palindromic sequences of 50-million
sequences of letters in the Y chromosome
over six million of them are palindromes
so again we can see the importance of of
beauty in the this kind of affirmation
of life now what is the literal claim
that is being made here we hear about
being rescued from a man killing sea or
we hear about a plank in the midst of
the ocean but what literally is being
said and I think there are a number of
literal claims that are being made the
one is that beauty restores our faith
our trust in the world and I'm sure that
many of you have had the experience of
being in a dire situation or working on
some very brutal subject and then
suddenly seeing something beautiful and
the sense of reassurance that that gives
it almost gives one strength to to
continue the project the second I think
literal claim is that beauty increases
our perceptual acuity it raises the bar
for what counts as perception sometimes
people worry that a beautiful face will
Rob attention from other less beautiful
faces or a beautiful building will
divert our attention from this building
project over here that's in need of
repair and when my students for example
worry about that I suggest to them that
they conduct the following experiment
the next time you're walking down the
street and like Socrates singing fie
dress you suddenly see someone or
something
makes your knees buckle because it or
the person is so beautiful ask yourself
were you walking along being hugely
mindful of everyone in the world and
being capacious and caring or were you
in fact walking along in a nearly non
state until this beautiful thing or a
beautiful person could be a mathematical
formula whatever wakes you up and then
that raises the bar as I said a moment
ago for what counts is perception and
either the person herself has the
ethical awareness to say the attention
that I'm giving effortlessly to the
beautiful face of this child deserves to
be given to her more cumbersome adults
surrounding her or if that person
himself or herself doesn't think that
somebody else might tap the person on
the children so you know the attention
you're giving to this building really
ought to be given equally to these
buildings over here now so far it sounds
like this life pact is one directional
that the perceivers are the recipients
of the particular life gift of beautiful
things and that we give nothing in
return but I think Obama's reflection
will tell us that when we see beautiful
things in the world that incites us to
care for them and to take care of them
for example it might be that the
beautiful thing is already a live thing
children and the infant's of most
species tend to be very appealing
immediately and it elicits a great deal
of care but a brook is a live thing a
meadow is a live thing now here's the
thing even if the beautiful object is
not alive for example a canvas a
painting is not alive but when it gets
stolen from the Gardner Museum or when
it gets stolen from the National Gallery
in Berlin people all over the world are
alarmed that its surface will be hurt
even though that surface is not alive
even though they may themselves never
see it or even a spy
to see it but they're just they they
perceive it as something that is wound
about and in danger now this gives us a
glimpse of beauty and the pact of
aliveness and what I want to contemplate
for the next few minutes is more
specifically that pact in the realm of
buildings buildings even at their most
minimal the small fragments of netting
that can be seen in this shelter a house
whether in its most minimal or its most
maximal form transforms us from being
creatures wholly at the mercy of rain of
strong sunlight of insects and of
crowded living conditions into creatures
who can merely by our passage from
inside to outside regulate the rains
ability to reach us or the sun's ability
to reach us or the number of people who
stand in our field of vision and of
course there's a reciprocal act going
back that that the person then has to
take care of the shelter and the more
magnificent your shelter the more care
you're going to have to put into it when
the hurricane comes to town now today I
think there's it's understood by
everyone that there are not just tens of
thousands but hundreds of thousands of
people moving across the earth
but when Sabater Salgado did his
migrations exhibit in the late 90s and
published this book on migrations in the
year 2000 it was a wake-up call to
everybody that that huge numbers of
people were in a nearly homeless state
moving across the surface of the earth
and I just want to focus for a moment on
two features of Salgado's migrations
exhibit the first is something that is
brought to mind by the work of Public
Health physicians who point out that
there's a difference between narrative
compassion and statistical compassion
we're pretty good at narrative
compassion that is when we're asked to
care about one person or two people or
three people but we're dreadful at
statistical compassion
and one thing about Salgado was that his
exhibit he's really one of the few
artists I can think of whose aim was to
elicit from us statistical compassion
since there were thousands of people
even tens of thousands of people in some
of his photographs and he photographs
people in many different places but all
three that I've just shown are from the
wand Rwandan camps in Tanzania the and
you can see by the way in this
photograph the shelters that are to the
going on the hillside up to your right
and the hillside up to the left and the
hillside out in front of you the second
feature is that they're beautiful and
you may know that when he did this
exhibit he was criticized for treating a
very dire subject with such beauty even
though until the day before he did the
exhibit no one was aware of that dire
subject and probably if it hadn't been
so beautiful not so many people would
have looked at it and you may also know
that he reports that when he was doing
this this the photographs no matter how
bad the situation was there were always
little children in the vision in the
field of his camera trying to get in the
way of the camera so he made a compact
with them that if they would just agree
to stay out of his field of vision he
would then make a portrait of them with
the result is that side by side with his
migrations exhibit is the exhibitor of
the book called the children which is a
series of portraits of individual
children and one of the things that's
striking about them is how often some
fragment of beauty is on the child
whether it's a necklace or bracelets or
a beautiful piece of textile so in this
child from Cambodia what are we to make
of the bracelets she's wearing
I think that that it's fair to say that
the bracelets are for her the law the
the plank in the ocean the life-saving
plank in the midst of the ocean in the
time when beauty was in taboo and
literature Department so it was a
widespread view which seemed to me
preposterous so forgive me if any of you
hold and probably some of you do that
beauteous middle-class and when I wrote
on beauty I didn't address this because
it seemed as though 15 seconds of
empirical experience would tell you that
people who are very rich often care a
great deal about beauty and people who
are very poor care a great deal about
beauty and that the love of beauty is
universal it's only the objects that
differ just as all our objects change
and by the way the plurality of beauty
is I think one of its most striking
features the plurality of beauty often
troubles people but we would be in a
terrible straits if we all chose the
same spouse and we would even be in
terrible straits if we all lived in the
same design of a house so the the the
the particular pictures that Salgado
ended up doing of the children are a
reminder that that beauty is is a life
saving across the board and and in all
in all economic classes in all countries
now a house is also alive I think and I
purposely taken a building in its most
minimal appearance a house is a piece of
materialized cognition a live act of
creation in which two mental events
merge and are then materialized in this
external world first the perception of
the human susceptibility to environment
second the counterfactual wish to be
free of the of the to free the person of
that environmental susceptibility and I
I write about the way in which this
works in other kinds of objects in the
chapter on the structure of artifacts
and the body and pain but a chair for
example a chair takes over the work of a
skeleton and relieves us of the problem
of body weight it would be hard to keep
thinking about other subjects if one had
to always be carrying one's own body
weight so one could say that a chair is
an externalized manifestation of the
human spine the human skeleton but that
would understate what a chair is because
if you if you imagine a person looking
at somebody and seeing the problem of
body weight and simultaneously
performing the counterfactual act of
wishing that problem to be gone if you
said what is the structure of that
perception the structure of that
perception is the chair so to a light
bulb
if you imagine somebody looking at a
human being and saying the person is
dependent on Sun and cannot is blind
half the day and then you imagine him
also saying having the counterfactual
which that that not be the case and you
say what is the structure of that merged
perception the factual perception and
the counterfactual act it is the
structure of a light bulb and was seeing
a much simpler instance of it in the
shelter now a second kind of building
that is on the cusp between life and
death is a hospital and I was out the AL
Medical School a couple of years ago
that I first heard about the research
that had been done in 1984 in Sweden by
a professor of architecture named Roger
all week perhaps you know this work
where a study showed that post-operative
patients who were in rooms that looked
out on a beautiful natural scenery
recovered from the operation much more
quickly and used much less painkiller
than matched patients whose windows
looked on to a brick wall
since that time as Nathan star writes in
an art of
the Canadian Medical Journal in a recent
issue of there have been 1200 studies
confirming the fact that healing is
assisted and speed sped up by the by
beautiful conditions and these beautiful
conditions usually involve a single
bedroom some kind of accommodation of
visitors a good acoustical environment
day like views of nature and in many
hospitals artworks and interior gardens
and if you look online under beautiful
hospitals you will find many articles
that say 25 most beautiful hospitals the
United States ten must be for hospitals
and the picture show they are indeed
beautiful and you might say oh this is a
competition but competition as Brooke
Hindle shows in his book called
emulation and invention which is about
the invention of the of the steam engine
and the towel and the Telegraph
emulation means there's a shared object
of aspiration and the shared object of
aspiration in this case is the healing
of the patients and the the healing
power of beauty the particular hospital
I chose is not in the United States and
I don't know if it's on any list but
it's very beautiful and it's by Moshe
Safdie in Colombia and it's a 400 bed
hospital that has its major axis a kind
of bamboo forest or bamboo Carter these
are two more pictures and many many of
the doors open out onto this bamboo
quarter and then in addition it I think
the bamboo quarter you can see in the
arcing green halfway down the building
but in addition it has what the firm
describes as five fingers that reach out
to the lagoon or Bay all of which
overlook a Healing Garden so that it
maximizes the person's access to some
beautiful vision and this is an aerial
photograph of that same building and the
rooms often are as in many hospitals in
the United States very airy and and
beautiful now one of the reasons I chose
this particular hospital is that Moshe
safdie's work as you know from habitat
67 has often been dedicated to trying to
solve the problem of how you have people
living who live in a dense situation
still have a great deal of air and light
and this is just one of his buildings in
Singapore that is called the Singapore
sky habitat with aerial streets and
gardens and there are many walkways and
and so forth and and yet if you if you
look at Moshe safdie's work all kinds of
buildings have that those same kind of
property whether it's a public library
in Utah or the Peace Institute in
Washington DC or the building that
honors the courage of soldiers that he
built in South Carolina I said a few
moments ago that one of the key features
of beauty is its plurality so if I
choose something that isn't your the
beautiful object you would think of if
you just take you imagine some other
object and test their principles of what
I'm saying against that object to see
whether it's true or not
now so far I've made good on or tried to
make good on the title beauty and the
path the subtitle beauty and the pact of
aliveness but there's that title that
mark conscripted me into well I think I
said the title and then he said yes
building and breath so now I have to
make good on it and I will do it by
talking about breath as air breath as
wind breath as voice I won't really talk
about breath as breathtaking except to
say that with
exception of people if you look across
all the arts it is architecture that
most often gets the adjective
breathtaking and I guess it's because of
the fullness of the presence of the the
thing being made but I'll talk at first
about beauty as air and there's a
wonderful architectural poem that
probably many of you know by the
Romantic poet Coleridge called Kublai
Khan and it starts out with this
underground world of caverns of ice and
by the end of the poem he's gonna a cert
that he can lift it up into the air so
I'm just going to show you the beginning
and the end of the poem in Xanadu did
Kubla Khan a stately pleasure-dome
decree where alph the sacred River ran
through caverns measureless to man down
to a sunless sea so twice five miles of
fertile ground with walls and towers
were girdled round and there were
gardens bright with sinuous rills where
blossomed many an incense bearing tree
and here were forests ancient as the
hills unfolding sunny spots of greenery
now as you can imagine there have been
many different sources proposed for this
poem some people say it comes from the
east some people say it comes from the
west from the Bible know from the Koran
from this century know from that century
I myself was struck this summer when I
was reading Marco Polo's on description
of the Mongol Empire in the year 1300
the same year in which Dante is writing
of how many details are being
transcribed that of Kublai Khan's
residents into into this poem that's
called Kublai Khan
for example meadows with rills of Brooks
running through them and walls within
walls within walls and a mountain that
that is built there that has evergreen
trees on it
and when we get to the end of the poem I
just the the italicized line that I'm
really want to focus on but a downsell
with a dulcimer in a vision once I saw
it was an Abyssinian made and
on her dulcimer she played singing of
mounted Bora could I revive within me
her Symphony and song to such a deep
delight would win me that with music
loud and long I would build that dome in
air that sunny dome those caves of ice
and all who heard should see them there
and all should cry beware beware the
poem is about civilization and it's
about war it's about voices of war and
about how to address both of them but
the source of that line and I will build
that dome in air has been observed by
the romantic scholar the scholar of
romantic poetry Jack stillinger as a
very direct echo of Michelangelo's boast
I will build that dome in air of st.
Paul's in in Rome and whether he
actually said it or not as contested but
in the 18th century and 19th century it
was repeated all the time that he had
boasted I will build that dome in air so
and my point is just that long before
Kublai Khan that is the actual Kublai
Khan and long long into centuries when
we are no longer living there is the
aspiration - of course to build an air
which can be demonstrated most simply
with a very familiar object the Eiffel
Tower now when you look at this
photograph you might suspect that I went
through every photograph of Eiffel
Towers and just chose the one that
looked Airy since I'm trying to talk
about building an air and your suspicion
would be right that is what I did and I
had to pay Getty a lot of money for the
permission to show even a bad quality of
this good photograph but I also think
that what it shows is actually the case
that it is of course very very Airy and
I will show this by posing a riddle then
I'll give an answer
which no doubt many of you already know
but don't say it aloud so everybody else
can work it out for himself or herself
and then I'll importantly tell you the
source of the riddle so you'll attribute
the cleverness of the riddle to my
teacher and not to me so here's the
thousand foot high Eiffel Tower and it
has many metal parts the official Eiffel
Tower website says it has 18,000
metallic pieces that together weigh
7,000 tons actually seven thousand three
hundred tons of metal and it required
over two million rivets and what this is
a picture taken of course standing
underneath it looking up so you can
appreciate the metal now here's the
riddle the question if you were to
collapse down the Eiffel Tower into the
Eiffel Towers footprint at the base the
410 square feet of the footprint at the
base and melted it down how high how
high would the pile or pool of metal be
and so can you take a calculate it for
yourself and then I'll tell you that the
answer is it would be under three inches
high which is a way of just appreciating
the fact that actually of course the
Eiffel Tower is very Airy now that is
something that I learned from a course
taught by an engineering professor
Stephen wrestler at West Point
it's called understanding the world's
great structures and I've taken this
course three times and some of the
lectures I've seen five times and
actually my favorite moment is when he
asks you how big the pile is going to be
and Stephen Ressler shows that that what
this is all possible because the basic
building material is the truss and the
Eiffel Tower is completely composed of
trusses within trusses which are
incredibly strong the triangle is an
incredibly strong structural unit as as
most of you know but the lay person like
me did not know and at the same
time very very airy and Ressler gives a
lecture on the trust where he traces it
from its first appearance in about the
first century Rome I was not in Greece
it was not in Egypt and he sees it on a
column the Trajan column there's a
bridge that is made out of trusses and
goes all the way up through cathedral
ceilings and up to IM pays pyramid
outside the louvre museum but this
particular image they found in the
Encyclopedia Britannica shows that the
trusses in certain building forms I'm
still very important and I think even
more impressive is the fact that the
many century long aspiration to lift
structures into the air can be best
appreciated by noticing that the
impossibly Airy impossibly strong
triangle truss is present not only this
in structures left standing in the air
but also in the tool that lifts those
structures into the air namely the crane
and if you look at the array of cranes
all of them are of course built of
trusses of triangles and this happens to
be in Hong Kong but it's - whether
you're in Beijing or in Shanghai or in
London or in New York City or wherever
that the trust is able to carry its own
weight and the weight of of men and also
much more than the weight of men so it's
amazing that's so minimal structure and
like the salgado tents the it's a kind
of minimal and delicate structure and
yet it can do all that heavy heavy
listing now I titled this building and
breadth in part also because of the wind
and I think that probably all are
actual students no but again as a
layperson I didn't know until I took
this structural engineering course how
much the load of the wind is the key
problem in any kind of building whether
it's a horizontal structure like a
bridge or a vertical structure like a
building and one thinks of the what's
called the dead load or the weight of
the materials themselves or the live
load of people walking across it or
trains or buses but apparently the wind
seems to play a big part as you probably
know in the famous story at the Tacoma
Narrows Bridge that in 1940 collapsed in
a relatively mild wind I think was 40
miles an hour began to vibrate and then
collapsed or you probably also know the
the story of the Citigroup skyscraper in
New York where the architect had
calculated the winds on the north east
south and west surface but not on the
quadrant northeast northwest at Soto
coming in on the corners and only when a
student called him and said exactly how
are you calculating those winds did he
did they they realized they had a near
disaster on their hands and had to
completely revise the building so as a
result of having a slight exposure to to
these these kinds of questions
I now see practically every building as
really a sail and I could go back
through most of the buildings we've
already encountered in this lecture and
and and see it in terms of the wind
for example the Eiffel Tower as
described by Eiffel himself is very much
a structure designed to accommodate the
wind the curvature of the uprights is
mathematically determined to offer the
most efficient wind resistant possible
all the cutting force of the wind passes
into the interior of the leading-edge
uprights lines drawn tend tangential to
each upright with the point of each
tangent at the same height will always
intersect at a second point which is
exactly the point through
passes the flow resulting from the
action of the wind on that part of the
tower of support situated above the two
points in question before coming
together at the high pinnacle the
uprights appear to burst out of the
ground and in a way to be shaped by the
action of the wind so to the earlier I
mentioned a building by or several
buildings by Moshe softie this is one of
his buildings in in the city of chang
chong ching that actually is covers ten
more than eight million square feet of
building and it's conceived of sails
upon the water it's at a place where two
rivers meet and again it's an attempt to
accommodate the fact that the pressure
of people having to live in incredibly
dense population centers and and and
still having light and gardens and so
forth and if I go back to my first
example of Odysseus I talked about the
beauty of Nausicaa but actually Nausicaa
is a midpoint in two building projects
when Odysseus goes out into the sea as I
said before he's endlessly tossed around
the east wind tosses him to the west the
west autism to the east the north to the
south the south to the west and he
realizes that he can only survive by
having an incredibly well built raft and
I won't read this whole passage but it's
a gorgeous passage about Calypso giving
him these beautiful shimmering tools the
handle of the axe is is made of olive
wood and all the she takes it to a grove
where the most beautiful long standing
trees are growing and he makes a raft
and we see it in full description when
he's on the ocean a goddess a malicious
goddess who's in league with Neptune to
destroy him tries to convince him just
to swim to shore and he refuses he will
abandoned his raft but when the raft is
finally destroyed he rides a plank into
Shore and even then he has a kind of
missus of a sail because he's wearing a
piece of cloth across his chest so it is
the building of the raft the raft is for
a time the thing that intervenes between
him and absolute destruction and when he
gets to Nausicaa her advice is that she
should please her mother in particular
because only if he does so will he get
the assistance he needs to get where to
his well-built home that is its to
return to another kind of building and I
hadn't noticed but a scholar has
recently pointed out a scholar named
Carol Doherty in in a book called the
raft of Odysseus that the only other
object Odysseus makes is in book 23 of
the Odyssey when he builds a bed an
immovable bed to register the fact that
he's home the other attribute of air
that I want to talk about is breath and
voice and buildings I think have a
emphatic relation to voicing as can be
seen for example in Stonehenge I'm
teaching a course right now and Thomas
Hardy and in one of his books Tess of
the d'Urbervilles test talks about the
fact that Stonehenge is humming and the
person she's with angel care listens the
wind playing upon the edifice produced a
booming tune like the note of some
gigantic one stringed instrument musical
archaeologists are now actually
exploring Stonehenge to see if it was
conceived of as a musical instrument
another quick example is the whispering
arch at clonmacnoise in which was a 12th
century addition to a fifth century
Abbey in the west coast of Ireland where
a priest or a penitent could speak very
very softly
to the crevice of this arch and it could
be heard with perfect clarity on the
other edge of the of the arch and the
same is true of one of the buildings at
Harvard Seaver Hall which I am licensed
to invoke because I read on Wikipedia
that venturi venturi said it was his
favorite building in America so it won't
seem to throw kiyul if I mention it but
but it's this arch that actually does
carry a very very soft whisper all the
way to the other side and it might seem
that these are just fanciful
registrations of the idea of voice but
if you remember that a building one of
the things a building is trying to
accommodate is is accommodating our wish
to be in a world with many other people
and yet to have some kind of control
over how much we're seeing of those
other people so the fact that that the
conic Norris can accommodate the
whispering voice of a priest or of
lovers and same with Seaver Hall is it's
just a registration of the fact that the
capacity for intimacy is is made
possible by in part by by buildings and
I think that you know there are
characteristic sounds of cities we often
say that there's a low hum going on in
cities and the crystallographer William
Bragg points out in his lectures on
sound that the reason for that is that
only low frequencies can have sound
waves that can sweep around corners the
high frequency waves aren't making it
around corners and therefore there is
this this this continuous low and you
know I was trying to think if I could
actually claim that a truss has a voice
and then I noticed on the way down here
that every cellphone tower
I passed was of course constructed of
trusses so I think what the point that I
really want to lead to is
beautiful things call on us to honor the
life pact and also call on us to repair
those pieces of architecture that
violate the life pact and I would like
to point out in the moments that remain
that our nuclear arsenal I mean the
United States nuclear arsenal is a vast
architecture that has no other aim than
genocide probably you know the most
recent words research on nuclear winter
which shows that if not 1% but 1/100 of
1% of the current arsenal is used 44
million people will die on one day and 1
billion people will die in the first
month it's also the case that of course
it's not just human beings but ball
birds all mammals many plants will be
immediately devastated as well it
happens that 90% of the weapons are
owned by Russia and the United States
everything from the blackout on this
side is owned by the United States
everything from the blackout on that
side is owned by Russia and these other
countries that whenever nuclear weapons
are heard about we hear about Iraq Iraq
has no nuclear weapons we hear about
Iran Iran has no nuclear weapons we hear
about North Carolina or 'the korea north
korea has between one and ten and by the
way the graph tells you that the they
couldn't fit all the icons on so you
have to take each icon and multiply it
by by five people sometimes think that
that this arsenal is a holdover the Cold
War nothing could be further from the
truth for example we have 14 ohio-class
submarines each submarine is the
equivalent has the equivalent of 4,000
Hiroshima blasts eight of those eight of
those submarines were made since the
opening of the Berlin Wall now four
thousand Hiroshima
is enough to destroy a continent that
means each ohio-class submarine can
destroy a continent the earth has seven
continents the United States has 14
ohio-class submarines and the Bush and
Obama administrations have arranged for
trillion dollars to upgrade our nuclear
weapons and most other countries are
therefore going to do the same thing now
this architecture is colossal if we were
right now in a submarine probably
probably we could only fit the base of
one missile in this room maybe two and
they would go up three stories and there
are 24 of them on each ship so you're
really in as one writer describes it a
kind of forest of the submarine so it's
a huge architecture the same is true of
our ICBMs in the Midwest the 450 of them
that are left but though these are
colossal they are nearly invisible
because they are under the sea or
they're underground and because we as
citizens we and our legislature have
been completely evicted from any say
over this and therefore are barely aware
that it goes on so in the in the book
that mark mentioned which is called
thermonuclear monarchy that tries to
show the complete dismantling of
governance that comes about with this
architecture where one man or one woman
the president of the United States has
first use powers to carry out genocidal
acts people are worried that this that
Trump will do this and and as well we
should be worried but it's a worry no
matter who is present because though
Trump may according to some people whom
I'm one be crazy nearly a hundred
percent of the time most people are
crazy a little bit of the time and have
only a few seconds in which to make
decisions at any rate this book opens by
proposing a metaphor for visualizing
this and here's the important thing
about this metaphor it is not
an exaggeration if anything it is an
understatement but it's simply a way to
reimagine it so I'll just give you the
first two paragraphs and the the
metaphor goes on for I don't know five
or seven or ten pages imagine that there
one day came to earth something sometime
in the future a solitary country with a
new technology that the technology has
let the solitary country station adore
or more precisely a series of doors
under the floor of every other country
of the world if the leader of the
solitary country ever feels imperiled or
impeded by another country he can open
the trap door and in a single day
eliminate the population of that rival
country because the arrangement of doors
beneath each national cloris sectioned
the leader can alternatively choose to
eliminate just part of the enemy country
1/4 of it or 1/3 of it he might choose
to open the doors beneath the floor of
the opponent's military installations
only thereby eliminating those
installations and say one thirtieth of
the country's population as a shorthand
this ingenious technology and the
policies that enable choose might be
called the flexible floor doctrine now a
number of Architects have made drawings
of this flexible floor and I'll just
show you them this one is made by
Carolyn de ER and you can see that we're
clear but the word nuclear starts in the
upper left-hand corner this one was made
by Magdalena ague and Magdalena put took
words from the text and inscribed them
around the various parts of the
architectural units of this floor and
the particular process she focused on
was this one though it was hard to
conceive of an international arrangement
with greater asymmetry and therefore a
greater unfairness the advance company
might the advanced country might come to
think of itself as fair even as the
fairest of Nations for it each day has
the power to annihilate millions of
people and each day or almost each day
of
stays from doing so other countries in
its views seem to hit each other with
sticks and stones every chance they get
the inhabitants of earth will find it in
their interest to agree with the lever
country's description of its own
generosity and here comes the sentence
that she that might glean it puts in her
picture they cannot influence whether
the flexible floor is absent or present
but only whether it stays closed or
suddenly drops open beneath them and
they can diminish the chance of its
dropping open beneath them by smiling
waving and in general being cooperative
and quiet and I don't know if you can
see the the words I'm here but she she
has other renderings and she has many
compartments in the floor as a reminder
that ordinary life is going on in this
world there's this architect as someone
who for some reason always puts cats in
her drawing and here their sister
maniacal cat who has installed this
floor beneath every other country and
I'm just going to show you two of the
drawings but she she actually made a
number of them here's another one where
they thermonuclear monarch is is is at
work anyway I hope but the key
aspiration of this lecture is that that
beauty will work on everyone to help
dismantle this architecture because it's
only if it's widely worked on that it it
will be dismantled and beauty has
already been seen as a call to work
towards the elimination of global
warming oh I'm sorry I forgot there's
one other rendering of the floor of the
world by Christine pop now this is Andy
Goldsworthy Andy Goldsworthy one of his
pictures from his new book of ephemeral
works and I think that many architects
use the beauty of the world to call on
us to have
repair injuries this is his taking of
Sycamore leaves beneath a sycamore and
putting them in a way that foregrounds
the root system and in fact in the case
of global warming which is obviously
also something we need to work on
although I would quickly say it's not
clear how to reverse global warming it's
very clear how to get rid of nuclear
weapons it's it's they're very compared
to global warming they're very easy to
dismantle and the the actual danger to
earth is much closer and will happen in
a much shorter span of time once it
starts to happen but the the fact that
beauty is used as a call is I think
audible in maya lin's what's missing
exhibit where you hear lots of species
that are in danger of dying out but it's
also present in all kinds of of journals
National Geographic Scientific American
Wired magazine the NASA website that
talks about climate change while also
reminding us that the that the earth is
is beautiful I talked about breath I
learned the other day that the the earth
itself is rising and falling eight
inches a day each day because of the
gravitational pull just as the oceans
have a big gravitational pull on them
there is a a geophysicist at MIT who
writes about the fact that there's a
kind of lift and fall of the ground on
which we stand so I hope that all of us
can can at some point work to rid
ourselves of this very life denying
architecture thank you very much
our voice our complaint
thank you very much
there's something so beautiful about
nuclear submarines that has to do with
what you do with that um I don't think
there's anything beautiful about the
photographs of Hiroshima the the
photographs of Hiroshima that we've
mostly seen are incredibly edited they
were at the beginning people were not
allowed to to publicize photographs of
what injuries look like I tried to do an
exhibit and did do an exhibit last
February at the Central Square Library
one of the libraries in Cambridge of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki and
understandably I mean it was wonderful
that Central Square Library let us do an
exhibit but the librarians took down the
pictures of the injuries which I
understand because people aren't
prepared even though if you go to
Hiroshima Museum you just see scores of
schoolchildren coming in and taking in
what those photographs look like the you
know the study was done of what
a nuclear explosion would be like in
Rotterdam if only a tiny Hiroshima size
13 kilograms was used and that is the
propose that a terrorist might get hold
of some material and bring it in what
the states have is vast by compared with
that and it's on alert it's ready to go
and the targets are assigned the targets
are assigned but even the small one you
know the effects come from radioactivity
the effects come from burns the effects
come from blast power the the number of
people who would be burned as twenty
thousand ten thousand of whom would live
but need critical care
ten thousand there are only a hundred
burn beds in Netherlands when I first
read that statistic I thought oh I
thought what Netherlands was a really
civilized country it only has a hundred
burn beds then I looked at the Mass
General website which is a leading
Hospital in the United States it has
seven burn beds so nuclear weapons
eliminate the right of self-defense and
they eliminate the capacity for mutual
aid there is no way to help with that so
I don't like I have seen a lot of
photographs of Hiroshima and I can't
remember one if you're talking about the
mushroom cloud the hibakusya the
survivors of Hiroshima say we saw no
mushroom cloud that's what people who
are far away saw that's what the
photographer on their Enola Gay saw it's
not what people on the ground see so and
nothing on the ground that I've seen
looks beautiful now the nuclear
submarine is a beautiful object and the
and and let me just say that in the book
I say you know we've got two huge
magnificent in terms of the work they
take inventions posed against each other
social contract and constitutions on the
one hand and nuclear weapons on the
other hand and each is spreading and
each can only spread if it can defeat
the other because if you have
constitutions you can't have nuclear
weapons and vice versa but
nuclear submarine as a ship as a
capacity go underground can be used for
many other things that can be used to
map the floor of the ocean it could be
used to you know maybe find more
efficient ways to get medical supplies
from a country that has them to a
country that doesn't have them I don't
think there's anything beautiful at all
about the missiles themselves or the
injuries they do in fact and not
everyone will agree with this people
fault me for not using the word ugly in
the book I don't understand these are
the word ugly in relation to beautiful
for me the opposite of beauty is injury
and there's no way that nuclear weapons
can can be eligible in in my view for
for it for that you know I think that
well maybe we'll go on to other things
oh thank you very much thank you I mean
this kind of subject matters makes your
head like exploited right where are you
oh oh I'm sorry
sorry it I mean it I don't understand
though how I mean I thought you used
that use of the term structure
perception was really interesting and
that that was and I'd like to hear more
about that but how do you mean you just
for the first time in stating that you
didn't wouldn't use the word
ugly but you say beautiful and injured
or the opposite would be injury that
just that alone trying to figure that
out in terms of the object or these kind
of status of beauty or the protection of
life seems to me very difficult to to do
I mean so I'm curious about whether
you've been tempted to give a kind of
taxonomy to the beauty that it's been
you know from the usual sublime to the
pretty or whatever or to engage with
parsing beauty some beauty produces
actually is beautiful because it's
completely indifferent to life in a
sense in that
soare technological sublime as Hiroshima
or whatever so I'm just curious about
whether you've been tempted to contend
with you know those his long
philosophical history of trying to
figure it out yeah yeah no I'm actually
not tempted to do a taxonomy other than
maintaining the opposition between
beauty and injury and there's a problem
with that which I'll come back to if
there's time but the in fact the the
even the division into the beautiful and
sublime is to me a stake and I don't
think Burke and Kant meant it to be
deleterious to beauty but if you look at
Kant's observations on the beautiful and
sublime which he wrote before the the
third critique it's clear that that you
know he that that the you know sublime
is Maskin the beautiful is feminine the
sublime is mighty and close to the
metaphysical and the beautiful is
diminutive it's like flowers in the
field so he took this whole field that
had been unified and and I think the
work of Burke and Kant was really
intended to extend the realm of
aesthetic objects to include things that
were mighty and fear-inspiring
but the result was that it divided what
had been a unified field and made it so
that the beautiful somehow was blocked
from access to the to the metaphysical
and in fact during the time when Beauty
was evicted and I was writing about it
was evicted from the humanities but then
I would hear from all kinds of people in
other realms art studios architecture
buildings museums many museum directors
said they I mean their museums are full
of beautiful things and yet they weren't
supposed to talk about beauty but during
the time it was evicted the word that
came in was sublime and to me the
confusion about that isn't nothing so
apparent as in the term which isn't you
know your invention you're just citing
at nuclear sublime it's it's like
speaking from
complete position of invulnerability too
you know and and now anything positive
can be enlisted into an evil act you
know we often think well if Beauty can
be enlisted into an evil act it must be
a flaw on beauty but we know from
history that there's actually nothing
you can think of motherhood has been
enlisted into evil acts by some regimes
the Solstice has been enlisted into evil
acts by some regimes so the fact that it
can be enlisted yeah it can be
but that isn't that that is a kind of
dismantling from the interior of the
thing itself now the problem with with
even the taxonomy that I'm giving a
beauty versus injury is that you don't
want to think that if you're injured
you're outside the realm of beauty but
the the point of it is that we always
have to be clear on being opposed to
injury I think several you know I think
might you might disagree but to my mind
you don't want the the species to get
confused about whether injury or non
injury is better and the the you know
let's say for example that I lose the
use of my legs and so you could say well
this the the opposition I'm proposing
isn't good because now it seems like I'm
you know outside any sphere but the
thing is that our first impulse has to
be when someone loses the use of their
legs to try and repair their legs and if
you can't repair their legs then you
revise the city so that it's no longer a
disadvantage to not be able to use your
legs you have ramps you a bus lifts
lifts etc etc but you don't start by
saying well leather have you know people
with injury or without injury I think
that's really a mistake
yeah but I understand that it's
something about which people can
sometimes disagree
you were time for one more question
hello hello so in your thank you for the
lecture by the way and your lecture you
talked about beauty but it was seems
very nature centric or potentially earth
centric especially this last slide we
can see it's very earth centric and in
the spirit of thermonuclear warfare
especially in world-ending scenarios
many the conversation is now heading
towards maybe a world is the earth is
not our human civilization is not as a
single planet life form and and that
question I would ask you how do you
think our conceptions of beauty our
conception or our conceptions of beauty
would change in a scenario where Earth's
nature is not the nature through which
we find beauty well you know one thing
that's really interesting is that to me
the people who are most aware of the
problem of nuclear weapons are
astronomers and like Martin Rees who's
the Royal astronomer of England and
there are a number of others and you
know first that struck me as peculiar
because there are everyday looking at
these incredible galaxies and wonderful
spiral this and that and so forth and
yet they are so worried about nuclear
weapons in a way that you know many
people just shrug off and spar from
their access to other galaxies
diminishing their sense of the
preciousness of Earth it magnifies it
you know it certainly seems the case
that there's life has to be life
elsewhere in the in the universe but it
so far appears that it's not
that common a an event and your your
right that I'm really emphasizing nature
here and there's there's you know I I
wanted to try and speak directly to the
question of building because you know
we're an architecture conference but my
more usual way of addressing the
relation of beauty and what it demands
of us in terms of nuclear weapons is to
talk about beauty and justice which
doesn't involve talking as much about
nature and involves talking about things
like symmetry and not just bilateral
symmetry but duo deca hedron's inside
octahedrons and so forth because every
theory of justice every theory of
justice entails asymmetry whether it's
it's talking about how you have to find
punishments symmetrical to the crime or
whether it's Rawls talking about
fairness as requiring a symmetry of all
our relations with one another and I
also talked about it in terms of the
notion given by philosophers some Simone
Bay and Iris Murdoch that beauty carries
out a kind of active on selfing it it
makes people selfless it makes them
willing to be marginal because you're as
iris Wright says you're all consumed
with yourself and your worries and your
insults that you've received and
suddenly you see something beautiful and
you you just are happy to be on the
sidelines and I think that's very
unusual because the the there are lots
of things in the world that produce
acute pleasure and there are lots of
things in the world that make you feel
marginal and beside the point
there are very few things in fact it's
only beauty that does it that can both
make you seem very marginal and give you
a acute pleasure and it's a very special
feature and and then the third feature
that I often emphasize is the one that
mark talked about of creation and it
and doing it this it causing a kind of
spread the beautiful thing will be
repeated and then repeated by someone
else and passed on and so forth and but
it it happens that you know as everyone
always says I mean I've seen lots of
pictures of other galaxies and they are
incredible but the it's hard to imagine
a planet more beautiful than Earth in
fact the one picture that I showed I
think at the beginning of when I was
talking about nuclear weapons that's a
particular photograph from NASA that is
considered the most accurate in terms of
the colours of Earth it's called blue
marble and it's the one they have lots
of photographs on there their site that
sometimes have to use colored filters
and so forth to get the features clearly
in view whereas this one is just an
accurate representation so so I'm you
know I'm happy to to see nature as full
of many problems and full of you know
rabies and tigers and hurricanes and
earthquakes but also many many beautiful
things
I want to thank mark her inviting Elaine
and thank Elaine for something I won't
give in to the temptation to call it
beautiful but it was a truly stunning
lecture truly stunning now I'm about to
invite you all everybody in this room
and in the other two rooms to our
reception we we are like to be
hospitable here at the school of
architecture and we have receptions
after our lectures recently this year I
should say under my tenure Robert
Simonson who is the noted cocktails
scholar and historian and the distilled
spirits writer for the New York Times
which i think is a title worth coveting
curates these drinks and tries to
connect them in some way to our speakers
tonight's drink is a version of the
Harvard cocktail it was created by
Robert actually specifically for Elaine
Scarry
it's a clear like the sky version of the
traditional Harvard cocktail the
traditional Harvard cocktail is actually
a brick kind of a brandy Manhattan this
version contains pisco which is a clear
Peruvian brandy with a white vermouth
and to quote the email that robert sent
me last week after reading a little bit
of your work as elegant and smooth a
drink as the writer herself so there you
go
you